So we're getting this perfect storm of incompetence,
arrogance and desperation to reopen the economy
from Republicans, that's leading to really,
really dangerous stuff.
And as you know or you may know, Donald Trump
has been talking about chloroquine with a
zip throw myson as a possible game changing
treatment or cure for Corona virus.
And as I've told you, there are some serious
side effects.
It needs study.
It has potential.
But some guy in Arizona has now died after
taking chloroquine phosphate, which is a fish
tank cleaning product related to the ingredient
in the medication.
It's not the medication.
I'll talk to you about that in a little bit.
But we now have Fox News propaganda, Sean
HANNITY, who's recommending a cocktail of
things as a sort of prophylactic to prevent
Corona virus as much as he seems to be saying
it also cures it.
And it's incredibly irresponsible and dangerous
for two reasons.
Number one, when you imply there's a prophylactic
for corona virus, which there currently is
not, that there's these, you know, vague speculation
based on very little data.
This can get people to behave very irresponsibly
and think they don't have to do physical distancing.
Number two, you're actually suggesting something
that can be dangerous for people to take.
Check this out.
Sean HANNITY did it during an interview with
Vise president Mike Pence last night.
Mr. Vise, president, I'm holding up a letter
and I'm going to read from it in a second
from a doctor, then New York area.
And if I may read from it.
He has now worked with his his associates
and he has a regimen, hydroxyl, chloroquine,
200 milligrams twice a day, five days, a zero.
Myosin, 500 milligrams once a day, five days,
zinc sulfate, 220 milligrams once a day for
five days.
This is what he has seen.
Him and his team of now treated approximately
350 patients and Kyra's chosen area of New
York.
Those hit particularly hard and another hundred
and fifty patients and other New York areas.
His results, we have had zero deaths, zero
hospitalizations, zero intubation.
So he refers to a doctor in the New York area
who gave this so-called regimen and treated
350 people in Curious Joel and another 150
elsewhere in New York with zero deaths.
So before we even look at the regimen, bear
in mind, first of all, curious, Joel is a
Hasidic Jewish community an hour north of
New York City.
The fact that a doctor had 350, quote, patients
in Curious Joel, which has a total population
of 24000.
To me, that suggests if this is even true,
it's overwhelmingly young people that they
are, quote, testing this on.
Why do I say that?
Hasidic Jews have many kids.
They have a lot of kids.
So when I hear this was tested on 350 people
and curious, Joel, I think these are all kids
and young people that would do fine anyway.
Plus, it's not even clear whether this was
being tested prophylactically.
He may be saying a doctor and curious, Joel
gave this to 350 people who didn't even have
coronavirus and they've not since gotten coronavirus.
That would be very, very meaningless.
And lastly, no deaths out of 350 patients
is meaningless when you're dealing with a
likely real death rate of under 1 percent
anyway.
So this is all very useless.
But when you look at the so-called regimen
hydroxy chloroquine, 200 milligrams twice
a day, five days, a zero myson, a once a day,
five days zinc, once a day, five days.
Zinc sulfate is just a zinc supplement.
There are a few people who say zinc is one
of the few supplements that might actually
help prevent the common cold, even though
we're not aware of any actual common cold
treatment.
One third of common colds are corona viruses
of sorts.
Most of the benefit of taking zinc seems to
be in people who are deficient in zinc in
their diet.
If you're getting enough zinc from your diet,
it's unclear that there's much or any benefit
from zinc.
Then you've got hydroxy chloroquine, which
is a drug that you can't just get it.
And unfortunately, people are stupidly thinking
that the fish tank cleaner with a similar
ingredient is the medication.
Somebody already died in Arizona from taking
that.
And then, of course, you've got his death-row
myson, which is an antibiotic.
Taking antibiotics unnecessarily isn't good
for you.
You also need a prescription for that.
So this is just crazy and irresponsible for
Sean HANNITY to be talking about on Fox News
as if it's anything at all.
Never mind something that prevents or cures
Corona virus.
Sean HANNITY also saying last week on his
radio show that he believes vaping may have
a protective effect in the lungs against Corona
virus.
Also, no evidence of that.
No, no good evidence of that.
Very dangerous stuff coming from Sean HANNITY
on Fox News and this coming during an interview
with Vise president Mike Pence.